just drive your car into the parking
garage a düsseldorf Airport and you
might think you'd entered a set of Star
Trek but these luminous panels are not
science fiction
they're already science fact passengers
can just leave their car and head for
the terminal it's valet parking courtesy
of Ray the robot that was on system a
admirer of several Transport Systems
explains this this system is easily
installed in parking garages without
elaborate additions his company has
developed a robot a driverless transport
system that picks up the cars and moves
them on the ground without special
installation wasn't silly endless thanks
to the slim construction of the robot
the cars can be parked closer together
using the garage space up to 60% more
efficiently ray can adjust a car is to
practically any size and with the help
of a computer find the optimal spot for
every model
the system also functions as a network
where several parking robots work
together to organize parking for large
numbers of vehicles they administer the
parking spaces putting some in long-term
storage or moving cars to the front when
required asking Myra says the system
works with almost any kind of car with
the exception of a few older American
models that are too long the system can
currently handle 98% of cars any model
that you would normally drive into a
parking garage can be parked here in
Quincy all [ __ ] airports are
interested in investing in these
futuristic garages because they offer
great benefits to travelers on the
special yet Airport head Thomas Naga
explains that the idea is to address
customers who want to park their cars
quickly to make their trips as efficient
as possible because the garage is so
close to the terminal
passengers are just steps away from the
check-in area and their flights second
Bashan Thamud off the effect of luke 6
of the robotic parking spaces are
currently available for passengers and
they've aroused lots of interest this
man says he gladly used the system if it
makes economic sense the parking robot
only adds 50 cents to the normal daily
parking rate of 29 euros per a maneuvers
around the deck with high precision with
the help of a measuring razor and
reflectors placed strategically on the
walls the flight database tells the
robot which vehicle to bring out next
based on the scheduled time of arrival
or a message from a smartphone Ray has
the car ready for its owner right on
time
you